i thought i'd talk about watts and gnats
and that's not as in the small intake
insect but n-a-t-s
n-a-t-s and w-a-t-s
all right you're gonna tell me what it
stands for you're gonna keep me in
suspense
so they're both acronyms nat stands for
narrow angle tail sources and watts
stands for wide angle tail sources
they're both kinds of radio galaxies i
think we made a video some time ago
talking about radio jets and talking
about the fact that when you look in in
the radio part of the spectrum at some
galaxies you find these enormous jets
coming out of them and they're
associated with a black hole in the
middle and the black hole is throwing
out material in in very energetic form
to produce these enormous jets of radio
emission it's this stuff called
synchrotron emission which is just
electrons and other charged particles
orbiting around the magnetic fields out
there and emitting radio waves as they
do it the watts and the mats are like
that except they're bent let me show you
a picture
so here's a picture
of both a watt and a net okay so that's
the what it's wide it's bent quite
gently and that's the net it's bent
enormously there so these are contour
plots we're just basically telling you
where the radio emission is so looking
at the nat there's the galaxy at the top
and then the radio jets are bent right
back right and in a what they're just
they just bend a little more gently in a
what than in a net okay so that's what
you were talking about first and then
that's a what and that's like that and
what's tend to be more kind of u-shaped
and that's tend to be a bit more kind of
v-shaped as well as being kind of
steeper they're just different extremes
of the same kind of thing but
astronomers like coming up with
classifications for things and so they
end up classifying them as different
okay and they're probably the same kind
of object that's just that's just going
to start a whole argument about when a
what becomes a nap
exactly and and you know it's not a
well-defined thing and you know you can
start trying to think up well why would
the jet not be straight and one thing
that could be happening is perhaps the
black hole in the middle or the
structure around the black hole in the
middle is getting kind of kicked around
right and so for example if two galaxies
have merged or if something had just
caused its inside to kind of wobble
around a bit but that doesn't do it
right because that would actually make
the the two ends go the same way and so
even if it was kind of doing different
things at different times you might end
up with something s-shaped that way in
that the jets were initially shooting
that way and then they was using that
way and when you sketch them together
you end up with an s or a z
but you'll never end up with a u-shape
and so it can't be anything internal to
the galaxy it's something which is
picking out a particular direction
external to the galaxy there are a
couple of forces that could be
responsible for bending the jets
probably the most important of the two
is round pressure that this is a galaxy
which is traveling through some cluster
or other and that cluster has its own
diffuse gas in it and what's happening
is these jets are smacking into that and
getting pushed back by it and then
becoming like flumes off the back of a
formula one car exactly so that's
probably what's responsible of it and
that's kind of interesting in itself
right because that tells you what
direction this galaxy is traveling in
right usually we can't tell you know we
can usually measure line of sight speeds
of galaxies because we can measure
doppler shifts in spectra and things but
we don't usually know on the plane of
the sky what way this galaxy is going
but if if this picture's right this
galaxy is clearly heading up this way
so it tells us immediately something
about the motions of the galaxy on the
sky as well as the fact that it's
traveling through a medium and so on the
second force is buoyancy it turns out
that these jets that are coming out are
actually less dense than their
surroundings so the material inside the
radio jet is almost a pure vacuum in
there it's much lower density than the
material around and when you've got
material of low density inside material
of high density gravity works the
opposite way around right but actually
things float right the way the reason
why a ball if you push a ball under
underwater it comes back up to the
surface again is because it's less
denser than the water so instead of
being pulled down by gravity it's
actually pushed up so the other force
that's almost certainly at play here is
that actually these things tend to float
away from the center if they're sitting
in a cluster with a pull of gravity and
the cluster pulling them one way that
the radio jets will tend to float away
the other way and that's probably what's
happening in this case in this because
you see in this in this galaxy here the
jet bends first one way and then the
other way and almost certainly what's
happening there is this galaxy's moving
off in this direction so there's round
pressure bending it that way but
eventually the buoyancy force becomes
the more important force and it actually
starts to float away from the center of
the cluster so it bends off in a
different direction this jet the
leftover jet that has now left its
parent galaxy is floating obviously in
the medium between galaxies in the
cluster and it's dense enough and it's
got enough stuff in it that we can like
see it and yet you're telling me it's
less dense than just the empty space
between the galaxies absolutely because
you don't need very much you know in
that jet you just need there to be
enough electrons and things whizzing
around to produce these radio waves so
you don't need a whole lot of stuff and
i always think of the space between
galaxies as being close to as
undenser places you can get and yet this
stuff's even less dense absolutely yeah
no it really really is and to the point
where it's probably a much better vacuum
although bear in mind that actually you
know clusters of galaxies you know
they're a pretty good vacuum but
actually there's much more stuff there's
much more gas
held in that potential well than there
is in you know away from that cluster of
galaxies in really deep space
so although they're a very good vacuum
there is actually a fair amount of of
material still in them of gas still in
them which we can see you know that gas
that surrounds the cluster that fills
the cluster gets very hot it's all
orbiting around very quickly it's
smashing into other bits of the gas and
so on we can see that gas directly by
looking at the x-ray emission from the
cluster if you look at one of the
relatively nearby clusters the perseus
cluster you can see there's been loads
of interactions where the central radio
source has effectively blown a whole
load of bubbles in different directions
at different times so it's a very
complicated story going on that gas
that's in the cluster isn't just sitting
there necessarily you know if clusters
are crashed into each other and so on
that gas will get stirred around as well
so there's actually weather going on in
that gas that this flows within that gas
which can complicate the picture as well
it's such big picture stuff isn't it
this is stuff that's all happening over
such time scales and such
mind-blowing it is distances there's one
final cute thing to say about this which
is if we go back to that example i was
looking at before this is a class a
radio source i studied with a phd
student what about blimey 30 years ago
now one of the problems is you want to
figure out okay so how much round
pressure is there right which means
basically how fast is this galaxy
traveling in this direction to produce
this round pressure and the answer is
you can't really tell because the amount
the jet gets bent
depends on how fast the material is
traveling along the jet right because
effectively you're kind of diverting the
jet so if the material is flowing along
really quickly along that jet
then a little bit of diversion is not
going to make it bend very much whereas
if it's traveling relatively slowly a
little bit of pushing it this way will
actually make it bend a lot so you
there's sort of this unknown in there
that we can't actually tell how fast
this galaxy is moving because we don't
know how fast the jets moving
but the cue pi is okay here the round
pressure's that's bending it is the
dominant force here the buoyancy is the
dominant force at just this point in
between those two forces balance each
other out they're exactly equal to each
other it's neither bending downwards nor
upwards it's it's straight there so the
buoyancy force is equal to the round
pressure force putting that extra piece
of information in
and we can actually calculate the
buoyancy force fairly directly because
we know how much gas there is there and
we can see how much it's bending so we
can actually figure out things more
about the buoyancy force that's enough
to remove that remaining ambiguity so we
can actually really say how fast this
galaxy is traveling and it works out
it's traveling a few hundred kilometres
per second typically velocities within a
cluster of galaxies can be thousands of
kilometers per second so it's going you
know at a relatively modest speed and
then once we've solved that we can put
that back into all the equations again
and say okay so how fast does that mean
the material must be traveling along the
jet to create this bend in this inner
part
and the answer there is a few thousand
kilometers per second which is also
interesting in that it's not hugely fast
right people think about material
getting flung out from these centers of
these galaxies at relativistic speeds
it's not relativistic speeds so by the
time it's out here it's slowed down
significantly it's still only only a few
thousand kilometers per second but it's
still a lot faster than the galaxy
itself is moving professor whenever i've
seen visualizations of these jets coming
out of center of galaxies they always
look like these incredibly powerful
violent like lasers or something that
you wouldn't want to get hit by but now
you've portrayed them with these
incredibly diffuse areas if i was in a
spacesuit out in
in you know
and was sitting in one of these things
would i even know i was in it so if you
were very close to the black hole in
these jets you'd know all about it
because there's gamma rays and x-rays
and all sorts of energetic particles and
things by the time you're out of these
very large distances there are still
quite fast moving particles and there
must be in order to produce to be
producing this radiation but it's very
diffuse right as we've just seen right
the density is incredibly low so i think
probably my recommendation is not to try
it but it's nowhere near as kind of
lethal an environment out there as it is
much closer to the black hole
because
it's
so much dimmer than all the other
galaxies in the cluster and also its
recessional velocity so you know the the
universe is expanding right so all the
galaxies are moving away from us you
expect
galaxies in the same cluster to move
away from us at the same rate